was mich seit geraumer Zeit umtreibt ist
eigentlich das Thema human Ressourcen
ist gar nicht mehr Fachkräfte
Arbeitskräfte sondern wo kriegen wir
unsere human Ressourcen her und die
Prognose sagen Prognosen sagen bis 2030
5 Millionen weniger in Beschäftigung
oder werbstätige gehen raus aus der
Beschäftigung dann da ist es aus meiner
Sicht völlig kontraproduktiv ein
Bürgergeld zu initiieren die Regelsätze
sind da gar nicht mein Thema mein Thema
ist im hohem Maße ein halbes Jahr
faktisch keine Sanktionen zwei Jahre
kann ich ihn schon Vermögen behalten pro
Nase 60.000 viele weitere Person 30.000
die Wohnung kann teuer sein es werden
die kompletten Heizkosten übernommen
nicht die Energiekosten die Heizkosten
und so weiter und so fort und wir haben
aktuell
und eine Million arbeitslose Fachkräfte
und wir haben ungefähr 1,2 Millionen
offene Stellen in dem Bereich insgesamt
haben wir zwei Millionen offene Stellen
wobei die echte Zahl der offenen Stellen
deutlich größer sind weil gar nicht alle
gemeldet werden
Zuwanderung ist sicher ein Thema aber
nicht Zuwanderung in Sozialsysteme
sondern Zuwanderung in unseren
Arbeitsmarkt und dann dazu was auch Frau
künne deutlich sagte ich habe mal vor
über 50 Jahren berufen oder Abitur
gemacht also ein Beruf gelernt Abitur
parallel und dann im Fernstudium meinen
Diplom als Informatiker rede ich nicht
mehr gerne drüber ist 40 Jahre her aber
gleichwohl auch zu sagen den jungen
Leuten nicht nur studieren sondern Beruf
ergreifen im zweiten Bildungsweg machen
und dann mit praktischer Erfahrung auch
ins Berufsleben einsteigen auch
kennenzulernen wie es handwerkliche
Tätigkeit und ich bin jetzt 68 Baujahr
alle meine Kumpels die Handwerksfirmen
hatten die sind in Rente in Ruhestand
gegangen ich muss jetzt zu Leuten hin
und dass der nächste Aspekt die ich
nicht mehr kenne und erwarte ich ihm ein
halbes Jahr ein Jahr und letzte
Bemerkung ich komme von der Küste der
Trend bei uns Hotel garni also kein
Restaurantbetrieb mehr mittags ist zu ab
17 bis 21 Uhr in Schichten Essen und so
weiter und ich muss sagen in dem Bereich
deutschsprachige Servicekräfte sind
mittlerweile sehr sehr rar gesät das
heißt einfach ich glaube diese
gesamtgesellschaftliche Debatte muss so
verschiedenen Ebenen laufen die Ebene
die Sie beschrieben haben der berufliche
Ausbildung eine duale Ausbildung zum
Meister bezahlst Du überwiegend selber
ein Studium wird überwiegend vom Staat
getragen das ist eine eine Unwucht sie
Wärme oder auch wieder in Schule einfach
Lust Spaß machen auf diese MINT-Fächer
und so weiter und so fort ich und
deswegen glaube ich wir gehen da
sehenden
in ein Dilemma rein was eigentlich heute
schon absehbar ist aber wo aus meiner
Sicht zu wenig dagegen getan wird am
Tisch eine Lösung Frau Wagenknecht viele
sehen sich ja nach ihrer Partei das
heißt wenn Sie jetzt mit ihrer Partei
sagen wir mal Kanzlerin werden was wäre
ihr Lösungsvorschlag ja also ob wir
gleich in Kaisers stellen aber jetzt mal
ernsthaft zu dem Problem also ich glaube
dass wir zum einen wirklich eine
Fehlentwicklung im Bildungssystem haben
wir haben auf der einen Seite sogar
verständlicherweise den Wunsch von ganz
vielen dass sie unbedingt studieren weil
sie das Gefühl haben dass sie nur dann
einigermaßen irgendwie ein Einkommen
erwerben das heißt wir haben in vielen
und auch weil Unternehmen teilweise
natürlich lieber zumindest Abiturienten
einstellen als Leute von Real und
Hauptschulen und das verstehe ich bei
den Unternehmen sogar weil das
Lernniveau bei Real schon ein
Hauptschulen einfach so grottenschlecht
inzwischen ist dass da eben elementare
Rechtschreibung und Mathematik oder
selbst Deutschkenntnisse oft nicht
vorhanden sind wenn man mit der Schule
fertig ist aber das ist natürlich eine
völlige Fehlentwicklung also es geht ja
nicht darum dass jeder studiert sonst
geht jeder darum dass jeder eine gute
Ausbildung bekommt das leistet unser
Bildungssystem zurzeit nicht und ich
finde da muss vielmehr investiert werden
einerseits Geld aber vor allen Dingen
auch Personal es muss auch mehr
Förderung geben für Kinder aus
Elternhäusern die nicht die nicht so
unterstützt werden also da ist ganz viel
zu tun das zweite ist natürlich dass wir
auch sind die meisten Mangel Bereiche
sind natürlich Berufe wo man relativ
schlecht verdient das werfe ich jetzt
also ich kenne selber zum Beispiel
Gastwirte also die am Restaurant und die
sind verzweifelt weil sie sagen wir
finden kein Personal wir müssen am
Wochenende zu machen weil wenn niemand
haben der da arbeitet aber es ist
natürlich trotzdem so dass man eben ja
in dem heutigen grad bei der heutigen
Inflation mit dem Gehalt wirklich nicht
klarkommt oder bei dem Bäckern ist es
eben sicherlich erst recht so also man
hat ja ganz harte Arbeitszeiten man muss
also zu nachtschlafender Zeit raus und
natürlich diejenigen die dort angestellt
arbeiten da können sie nichts dafür weil
natürlich müssten sie ist ja sonst erst
recht über die Kosten weitergeben aber
haben heute ein Lohnniveau das kaum zum
Leben reicht da hat sich viel verschoben
das war mal anders also es gab diese
große Kluft in Deutschland mal nicht
zwischen einem Niedriglohnsektor der
kaum zum Leben reicht und auf der
anderen Seite spitzenverdiensten in
bestimmten Bereichen die exorbitant sind
und ich finde wir müssen das wieder
schließen also es muss tatsächlich in
jedem Beruf und gerade in handwerklichen
Berufen wo extrem auch harte Arbeit
geleistet wird muss eben insgesamt ist
auch gesellschaftlich möglich sein ein
Lohnniveau
das wäre auch ein Weg natürlich auch zum
Beispiel Freibeträge deutlich anzuheben
und stattdessen meinetwegen richtig
Spitzenverdiener oder sehr große
Vermögen mit Millionen oder 100
Millionen das gibt es ja alles in
Deutschland dann entsprechend steuerlich
stärker zu belasten ich meine ich fand
ja interessant dass die
Wirtschaftsweisen jetzt sagen den
Spitzensteuersatz aber da muss man auch
sagen
haben mit Kohlbach bei 53%, aber er war
höher also er setzte höher an was das
Gehalt angeht und dafür bin ich ich bin
finde das ein Bundestagsabgeordneter
durchaus ein höheren Spitzensteuersatz
bezahlen kann aber nicht ein Mittelpunkt
und Einzelunternehmen und den privaten
nicht unterscheiden das lässt dieser
Steuerrecht nicht zu und eins bei der
Debatte immer nicht zu vergessen wenn
ich über höhere Löhne rede dann rede ich
auch eine höhere Kosten und ein Euro
brutto sind zwei Euro Personalkosten und
drei Euro leisten ja natürlich wäre es
möglich da Dinge auch zu entlasten ich
habe ja nur gesagt die Unehrlichkeit ist
ja immer dass die Politik natürlich
gerne erzählt wen sie alles entlastet
aber nicht gerne dazu gesagt wo das Geld
herkommen soll und das ist ja schon die
Frage die dazu gehört ich hatte noch so
schlecht sind die steuernamen des
Gesamtstaates im Augenblick nicht am
Ende angekommen ich habe noch eine
letzte Frage an Frau Wagenknecht meine
politischen Ohren war natürlich gespitzt
bei ihrer Aussage ob wir gleich den
Kanzler stellen heißt es denn dass sie
die eigenen Partei gründen werden nein
das ist noch nicht entschieden also ich
bin Mitglied einer Partei und ich meine
ich sehe dass wir in dem politischen
Spektrum das ist eine große Lehrstelle
gibt und das ist ganz viele Menschen
gibt die sich nicht mehr vertreten
fühlen und ich bedauere dass die Partei
der ich angehöre diese Menschen offenbar
nicht mehr vertritt bzw die sich auch
nicht mehr von ihr vertreten fühlen ich
halte das für ein Problem für die
Demokratie wenn immer mehr Menschen
nicht mehr zur Wahl gehen oder aus Wut
am Ende Parteien wählen die wir uns
vielleicht alle nicht wünschen dass sie
stärker werden insoweit ist
Handlungsbedarf aber es ist in
Deutschland sehr sehr schwer sowas neu
zu starten